It's been called black gold.
Large sacks of charcoal
illegally hauled out of Virunga
National Park,
a supposed sanctuary
in the Democratic Republic of Co
known
for its endangered mountain gori
and the dense forests they live
But it's the trees that are draw
these desperate people to Virung
The timber can be cut
and burned to make charcoal.
The lumber used for firewood.
The sale of either could determi
if a family eats or not.
It's a way of survival
for many of the tens
of thousands of refugees
who have taken shelter near Viru
after the M23 militia renewed
fighting against government forc
just over a year ago.
After nearly
a decade of relative inactivity
control of key cities
in the eastern part of the count
in the past
two months,
more than 200 hectares,
about 500 acres of parkland
have been reduced to stumps
because of illegal logging.
Some of the refugees say
they have little choice.
They between government and coun
Since we have been in the refuge
Humanitarian aid has not arrived
it's been three months since we
any help.
So instead of starving,
we come to cut wood in the park
Officials in Virunga
say it's a difficult task
to protect the wildlife
and natural resources
in Africa's oldest national park
Not only from the refugee guys,
but from poachers
and other longtime threats
in Basra,
there is a need among the displa
A need for firewood.
But on the other hand,
we have an obligation
to protect the park.
But aside from the presence
of displaced people,
it's also worth
pointing out the activism
of armed groups,
M23 and other militias operate
in the park vying for territory.
Some refugees say
the armed groups are exploiting
charging them to enter the park
and gather wood
or forcing them
to pay taxes on their earnings.
Even Virunga is park
rangers say it is dangerous
in certain areas for them.
In December,
two Rangers were killed
and another wounded
by suspected militiamen.
There have been efforts
to mediate the conflict with M23
A cease fire
last year raised hopes
that eventually
some displaced people could retu
But the government says M23
has not fully complied with the
by withdrawing from some areas
only to regroup in others.
And there are growing regional t
M23 is a mainly Tutsi group
that captured territory near the
with Rwanda.
The DRC,
along with the United States,
has accused Rwanda
of supporting the rebels,
which Kigali denies.
All the instability could add
to the number of displaced peopl
near Virunga,
which means more pilfering of th
That's bad for the park
and bad for the people taking re
near there.
Both of which are in
need of dire protection.
Michael Holmes, CNN,